[Music]
All
right. Good afternoon, everyone. Good
afternoon. A good afternoon it is.
Yes.
>> with Advent Media Connect. Yes. It is an
honor. We are excited because we know uh
This has been a long time coming. Yes.
Yes. I have been very anxiously
anticipating
this interview, this question and answer
session. So, I don't think Pastor Skeete
needs really any introduction, does he?
No, he doesn't. He doesn't. I think the
whole world know
who Pastor Skeete
>> know. Yeah.
>> Tell us a little bit about how you have
been impacted by him. Oh, just those
messages. His preaching just gets the
job done for me. Yeah, and I've met him
in person. I was telling him we've met
2017 when BJ was born.
Yeah. There's that image, you know. So,
Well, let's not waste any time. We only
have him for an hour. So, let's make the
best of this. Welcome to the channel,
Elder Pastor Randy Skeete.
>> it. I appreciate it. I really do. Yeah.
We are so glad to have you. Mhm. It's an
honor.
Your preaching has been a blessing to
our lives. You have no idea. You have
I know it's the Lord Right.
Right.
>> We give God all the glory. But, thank
you for opening your mouth and allow him
to put his word in
You have touched hearts and lives in
ways that you could never imagine. So,
thank God for you. We appreciate you and
also thank you for being here as well.
Praise God. Praise God alone. Mhm. Amen.
The first time I was fortunate to meet
you in person, I remember everyone was
going through the line and asking you
different questions. Mhm. Right when we
had our 8-year-old. He's 8 now. But, at
that time, he was months old and I said,
"Pray for our baby and bless him."
That was September. Yeah. That we met
him. Oh, he was 2017. Okay. Wow. So, he
BJ wasn't just born. He was
very much so newborn, but I we prayed
over him and blessed him and that was
>> he did.
He's still he's still a blessing. Yeah.
Well, yes, it's a God good glad to hear
that. God bless him powerfully. Mhm.
Amen. Amen. Yes. We have you for an
hour. Uh
we want to make the best of that time.
Mhm. Um I'm going to let my wife start
with a word of prayer and let's get
into this. All right, go ahead.
Heavenly Father, Lord, we are just so
glad to be here in your presence, for in
your presence is fullness of joy and at
your right hand are pleasures
forevermore.
Oh, Holy Father, Lord, we put our time
in your hands. You are the author in
time. You are the
alpha and the omega. You are the
beginning and the end and we are
anticipating a high time to just hear
more that you have put on your man
servant's heart. In this moment, Lord,
cast out any thoughts, any doubts, any
fears, any anxieties that we might be in
tune with you.
Father, we ask forgiveness of any sin
that has separated us from you and in
this moment we just ask that your Holy
Spirit will penetrate each of our hearts
and the hearts of the listeners. And
Father God, as your man servant goes
forth to answer these questions, may you
imbue him with the power of the Holy
Spirit to divinely interpret your word
aright so that your people, Lord, may
hear you and know that you are present
in their lives. We pray and ask this
prayer by the power, honor, and glory in
the name of Jesus Christ and the Holy
Spirit we pray. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Amen. All right. Well, let's
begin. I do have a list here.
Uh question number one, according to
scripture, um
how does God define the church? Mhm. You
distinguish the significance and value
of the organization. All right. How does
the Bible define the church? Let's take
a look at the book of Acts. I'm sure you
have your Bible with you. Go to the book
of Acts, we read chapter 7 and verse 38.
We read it microscopically.
Acts 7, reading verse 38.
This is at This is Stephen referring to
Moses.
And either you or your wife can read
that verse. This is he
This is so Acts chapter 7 verse 38.
Okay. That's right. Mhm.
All right. And there
reads, "This is
This is he that was in the church in the
wilderness with the angel speak unto him
in the Mount Sina and with our fathers,
who received
the lively oracles to give unto us."
Now, the Israelites in the wilderness
are referred to as the church. And the
Greek word there is ecclesia. Some
translations say assembly, some say
congregation, but the word church is a
proper translation, is based on
ecclesia. Ecclesia very simply means a
calling out. It is based on two Greek
words, ek meaning out,
kaleo meaning to call. So, the church
biblically is defined as a group that is
called out. And so, God called the
Israelites out of Egypt. He called his
people, the people of the descendants of
Abraham. So, the church is a calling out
from the world. Now, let's go to John
chapter 15.
Mhm.
Okay. John 15, let's read from verse 16.
Okay.
You ready? Mhm. You have not chosen me,
but I have
you
and ordained you that you should go and
bring forth fruit, that your fruit
should remain, and what that so that
whatsoever you shall ask of the Father
in my name, that
um in my name he may give it you. Okay.
Here again we This time we have Jesus
saying he's referring to the the seed of
the early church, the 12 disciples. I
have chosen you and clearly he chose
them out of the world. And we I'll be
taking you from verse to verse, so I'm
not giving my opinion, but letting you
know what the Bible has said. Go to John
chapter 17, read 6.
John 17 verse 6. Okay. I have manifested
thy name unto the man which thou givest
me.
Out of the world. Mhm. They were Mhm.
givest them me. Mhm. They have kept thy
word.
>> As I hear Jesus refers to the disciples
of those taken out of the world by the
operation of the Father through the Holy
Ghost, of course, and given to Jesus
Christ. And so, the church is a group
that is called out or taken out with
vehicle operation, of course, out of the
world. Here's what Jesus prays to the
Father on behalf of the church. Staying
John 17, read verse 15 or 14 and 16.
And 16, by the way. Those three verses
of John 17, 14, 15, 16.
I have given them thy word.
>> Mhm. And the world have hated them. Mhm.
They are not of the world, even as I am
not of the world.
>> And so, we have inherent in that
statement a definition that the church
of God is a group that functions
differently from the world. Keep reading
15 and 16.
I pray not that thou shouldest keep
shouldest taken them out of the world,
that thou shouldest keep them from the
evil.
>> Now, verse 17, the word world there
means I'm not asking you take them from
the physical world and re
relocate them to Mars, but keep them
from the system of the world because
there are two systems, God's system and
Satan's system. The church is a group
called out from Satan's system to
support the system of God. And so, Jesus
prays to the Father, "I pray not that
thou shouldest take them out of the
world, but that thou shouldest keep them
from the evil." And verse 16 repeats the
sentiment in verse 14.
Mhm.
All right. You want me to go back to
verse 14?
>> Yes, 16. Just 16. 16. Okay. They are not
of the world, even as I am not of the
world.
>> Now, in other words, then the church is
a group whose business is to reflect
Jesus Christ. The same way I am not of
the world, says Jesus Christ, they are
not of the world. Now, go to Matthew 16.
Mhm. Okay. Matthew 16, I'm there. Yes.
We read from verse 13.
We go down to 17.
When Jesus came into the coast of
Caesarea
>> Caesarea. Mhm. Caesarea Philippi, he
asked his disciples, saying, "Whom do
men say that I, the Son of Man, am?"
Mhm. And they said, "Some say thou art
John the Baptist, some Elijah, others
Jeremiah or one of the prophets." He
said unto them, "But whom say ye that I
am?"
And Simon answered and said, "Thou art
the Christ, the Son of the living God."
Go on. Go on. Jesus answered and said
unto them, "Blessed art thou, Barjona,
for flesh and blood hath not revealed it
unto thee, but my Father which is in
heaven." Now, listen carefully to verse
18.
And I say also unto thee, that thou art
Peter,
and upon this rock will I build my
church, and the
>> Now, we have Christ talk There's people
who say they don't believe in churches
and organizations. A part of the
question was organizations and religions
and structure. Jesus said, "I will build
my church on this rock." The rock, of
course, is not Peter. The rock was the
statement he made, "Thou art the Christ,
the son of living God." Now, that the
Jews understood that anyone claiming to
be the son of God is claiming to be
equal with God. That's why they tried to
kill Christ in John 5: 6-18.
He claimed to be the son of God, making
himself equal with God. And so, the
statement that Jesus Christ is fully God
is the rock upon which Christ builds his
church. And so, the church now, from all
the texts we've read, is an organization
that God a group that God calls out of
the church out of the world. The church
cannot call itself.
A divine power must issue that call. No
one is self-called to serve Christ. It
is the active work of God, but the call
can be resisted. So, this call, this
this kaleo, calling out of the world,
kaleo, this is the church, a group that
answers the call, and they realize their
primary purpose on the earth is the
reflection of Jesus Christ. That's why
he says, "They are not of the world,
even as I am not of the world." And he
says, "I will build up this church." Not
a building, because buildings became
commonplace in the 3rd century,
particularly when Constantine became a
Christian, so-called. Prior to that,
people met in houses. The church was a
group of people called out for the
purpose of advancing the kingdom of God
in opposition to the kingdom of the
devil. And so, that long response is my
answer to the question, "How does the
Bible define the church?" It is a group
that God has called out. That calling
out does not go back only to the
Israelites, it goes back to Abraham when
God called him out of Ur of the
Chaldees. And the reason why God called
him is found in Joshua 24:1-3,
"Your father served other gods, so I
called you out that you may practice the
worship of the true God." And God must
have a church on this earth today that
upholds the worship of the true God.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
My pronunciation earlier was Mount
Sinai. Sorry about that.
>> Okay. It's okay. It's okay.
I was like, did I say Sinai?
So, uh we're moving into
uh second question, which we're kind of
looking into personal faith, suffering,
and the Christian experience.
>> Mhm. How should a Christian respond
biblically and compassionately to those
experiencing social injustice or
oppression? All right. It's a very very
legitimate question. Now, the purpose of
the gospel
is to prepare people
to meet with God and live with God and
function in God's kingdom. Now, the
gospel cares about people's condition
now, not simply in the world to come,
because the world to come has not yet
come physically. We're still in this
world. The Christian does whatever he or
she can to ease the suffering. That is
why Christ gave the parable of the good
Samaritan. He was on his way to church,
uh he was traveling somewhere, he was
attacked, and a good Samaritan saw him
and helped him, and Christ, without
saying so directly, he he actually
condemned the Levite and the priest that
passed by and did not help that man.
Those two men were on their way to
church. A church that disregards the
physical suffering of people is not
reflecting the character of God. But
having said that, let me say this.
When you use the word church, when I use
the word church, I'm not simply
referring to every religious
organization that meets in a building.
That is church, because Babylon is a
collection of churches.
When I as a Seventh-day Adventist, I'm
referring to the remnant church of God
on earth, and I use the word remnant
very deliberately, despite the fact it
is fallen it has fallen out of favor in
the church today. I'm referring to God's
remnant church, and they have a
responsibility to ease the sufferings of
those in society. But I also wanted to
say this, the primary function of the
remnant church is not simply to ease
physical suffering, because if all
physical suffering were eased, that
would not solve the sin problem.
And I hope that's clear. If all hunger
were eliminated, all homelessness
eliminated, all joblessness eliminated,
all divorce eliminated, that would not
solve the sin problem. The solution to
the global sin problem is the full
introduction of the kingdom of God at
every level, not just spiritually or
doctrinally, but literally, physically,
and three-dimensionally.
And so, the primary function of the
church is the proclamation of a message
we call the three angels' messages,
particularly the third angel's message.
But in the procla- in the proclaiming of
that message, we do not ignore
suffering. So, where we can ease
suffering, we do that. Where we can ease
hunger, we do that. Where we can provide
clothes, we do that. But doing that
should not lead us into thinking this is
the only reason why we exist, because if
that's the case, we're no different from
the Salvation Army or the World Food
Program. We were raised to deliver a
message that will ultimately bring back
Jesus Christ to this earth. But again,
let me say, in carrying that message to
the world, we care about those who
suffer. And so, yes, the church has a
responsibility to attend to the
suffering of those around it.
Amen. Amen. Uh so, I appreciate what you
said, and you said we would end up
looking like the world, which brings me
to our next question.
>> Mhm. Seventh-day Adventist be concerned
about the church's non-governmental
organization NGO status with the United
Nations, and how should this be
evaluated biblically?
Now,
God calls his people to live a very
extreme life,
because the system we call to represent
is the absolute opposite of Satan's
system. The system of the world and the
system of heaven are two extreme
opposites. When God called the
Israelites out of Egypt, one of the
words he gave to them and the counsels
was, "Do not form alliances with the
surrounding nations.
Don't do that. Don't make covenants with
them, neither for marriage or for any
other kind of covenant."
Excuse me. As a matter of fact, Ellen
White counsels us, "We are not sorry to
enter into business arrangements with
non-believers." And by non-believers, I
mean non-SDAs.
Because they do not understand our
particular mission, and that all that we
do, ideally, should be devoted to the
advancement of that mission. And so, the
church should avoid connection with
worldly organization that commit the
church to that organization in the sense
that there legal implications and there
perhaps uh other requirements and
obligations that the church may be
forced to carry as a result of that
connection. So, as much as the church
can, it should keep itself free from
these entanglements so that nothing
prevents it from presenting a clear
message. Because if you're somehow
contractually connected, that connection
may prevent you from fully declaring the
third angel's message. It may prevent
you from identifying who Babylon is,
because Babylon may include the very
organization to which you're connected.
And so, the church must keep itself free
from unnecessary connections to secular
organizations in order that nothing may
slow down, impede, impair, harm, or
hinder the proclamation of our peculiar
message.
Amen.
NGO or whatever you call it, if it will
in any way interfere with our message,
we cannot have that connection.
I hope we don't get you in trouble for
that one.
No, it's okay. It's okay. I'm
I'm accustomed getting into trouble.
Oh, good.
All right. We have another question from
a person online. Mhm. F R, please. The
question that we have, in my capacity as
a health reform advocate, a Seventh-day
Adventist pastor inquired about my
stance on whether eating meat is a
salvation issue. I referenced the Spirit
of Prophecy, which asserts that
individuals who consume flesh will cease
to walk with God's people, and Genesis
1:29, he also referenced. This led to a
subsequent question regarding Jesus'
consumption of fish. How would you
respond to these questions in tandem?
When answering any question about the
Bible, we must never step off
fundamental principles. Mhm. You don't
shut out of heaven because you eat meat.
You shut out of heaven for disobeying
God.
Let me say that again. You are shut out
of heaven. You exclude yourself from
fellowship with God by deliberate
willful disobedience.
Now, we know that we're counseled not to
eat meat. We know before sin the diet
was plant-based. We know after sin is
eliminated, the the diet will be
plant-based again. We know that eating
of flesh is the result of sin. God
allowed it because vegetation had been
destroyed.
It is still the best choice to follow a
plant-based diet. Now, there are some
people who are not convicted yet. You
see, conviction is the work of the Holy
Ghost, not the result of a logical
argument. And so, let's say I'm a
medical missionary, I present the health
message, someone listens, is not
convicted. Ellen White ate meat for
decades before she finally gave it up
entirely, and I believe in 1894 or 1895,
but she got the visions in the '50s and
'60s. She was finally convicted
powerfully and she laid it aside
completely.
And so, when it comes to eating meat,
if God convince convicts you do not eat
it and you do, yes, you shut yourself
out of fellowship with God eventually if
you persist on that path of
stubbornness. Now, in last day, I think
it's last day event speech to uh not
last day event, sorry. Uh L White in her
last attendees at general conference
session in 1909, she gave a statement in
the testimony volume nine, page 159, I
think it is, 159 to 166, you can read
that whole section. She makes a
statement, "In countries where fruits,
grains, and nuts are in abundance, flesh
food is not the best choice for God's
people." Now, you look at that, this is
towards the end of life. She can look
back over decades of health counseling,
here is what she says, "In countries
which clearly indicates there may be
places where people have no choice but
to eat what is fish or meat or whatever.
That's clean, of course. In countries
where there is not an abundance of
fruits and vegetables and grains,
where there is, sorry, an abundance,
flesh food is not the best choice." Now,
in the United States, you can get
fruits, vegetables in certain most parts
of the country,
but even though there are places called
food deserts where you really cannot. In
most Western countries and in several
non-Western countries, fruits, grains,
nuts are available in abundance.
But the statement from the servant of
the Lord clearly implies there are
places where those choices are not
available. And in those cases, we cannot
condemn people whose only choice may be
fish or meat.
But generally, as a principle, we are to
avoid flesh meat. Now, for those who say
Jesus consumed meat, well, yes, Jesus
did consume fish more than once in the
Gospels.
But Jesus did not live after the day of
atonement began.
You see, the day of atonement began
October 22, 1844. It is the antitypical
fulfillment of the day of atonement in
the the days of the Israelites in in in
the wilderness, which was the uh the the
the sixth of seven of the annual feasts.
Now, on that day, no meat was taken into
the holy place or the most holy place.
No meat was taken in there. Are you with
me? On other occasions, the high priest
would take meat into the holy place,
consume the meat there as a way of
identifying with the sacrifice and with
the sinner. But on the day of atonement,
this was not done. No meat was taken
into the most holy place. And since
1844, the veil has been open, we have
entered into the most holy place, and
those of us who understand prophecy, we
do not take meat into the most holy
place. You see, we're no longer in the
era, prophetically, of meat eating if we
have the knowledge.
But we must not condemn those who do not
have the knowledge. We must not condemn
them those who have not yet been
convicted. L White says the health
message must be progressive, in other
words, people grow and grow and grow in
the knowledge of what to eat and what
not to eat. If you're talking to a man
who's eaten meat for 40 years, you give
him a lecture, how can you expect him on
the spot to become a vegetarian like
Adam was before he sinned? This is
unreasonable. It is progressive. But let
me say again, God's ideal for his people
is that which will give us health, not
only physically, but physical health
enables us to understand spiritual
messages from above. And so, the health
message is absolutely important, not
only to normalize blood pressure or
whatever else, but it is essential for
our spiritual development because
physical sickness has a negative effect
on spiritual growth. And so, I will not
run around telling people, "If you eat
meat, you're not going to heaven." I
need to understand the circumstances. By
the way, the L White estate has
addressed this question and they have
put out a statement, not an official
statement, but in responding to someone
who sent a note to them on this very
question, that we must be careful how we
charge L White with saying people who
eat meat will not go to heaven.
Because that's not a direct quotation
from her. That's not what she absolutely
meant. But let me say it again, God's
preference is a plant-based diet. That's
the way it was before sin. That's the
way it will be after sin. Eating meat is
allowed because of sin. It is not ideal.
And if you're Seventh-day Adventist and
you realize L White has told us clearly
most cancers and tumors are the result
of a flesh diet, if you understand that
and you still engage in a carnivorous
behavior, then surely you're
disqualifying yourself for a world where
all is physically and spiritually
perfect. Mhm.
Praise God. All right. All right.
There's one question we're going to take
online. We don't take too many, again,
but this one I think you can you can uh
you can manage that one. Mhm. And Pastor
Randy Skeete, give us practical steps on
how to grow spiritually.
All right. The Bible I'll give the Bible
off me, the Bible.
Listen, go to 2 Peter chapter 3, verse
18 and see what we can extract from that
verse to answer this very, very good
question. 2 Peter chapter 3, verse 18.
This is what God says to the person who
put the question and to us trying to
answer that question.
2 Peter 3:18. But grow in grace and in
the knowledge of our Lord and Savior
Grow in grace and in the knowledge of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. Now,
listen to John 17:3, we all know it
well. This is life eternal that they
might know thee, the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom thou has sent. Now, so
we have knowledge again. Go to 2 Peter,
where we are in 2 Peter chapter 3, read
verses 2 and 3 of 2 Peter chapter 1.
2 Peter chapter 1, verses 2 and 3. Read
those two verses. Okay.
Grace and peace be multiplied unto you
through the knowledge of God and
Through the knowledge, so we have the
knowledge again. The person who asked
the question, "How do I grow?" We say
knowledge, knowledge, knowledge. Keep
reading.
According as his divine power has given
unto us all things that pertain unto
life and godliness
through the knowledge of him
Through the knowledge. Now, look at 2
again, "According as his divine power
has given unto us all things that
pertain to life and godliness through
the knowledge of him that has called us
to glory and virtue." Now, read verse 4.
Whereby are given unto us exceeding and
great and precious promises Pause now.
These exceeding great and precious
promises, this is knowledge.
Through this knowledge, now, finish
verse 4, "That through these
That by these you might be partakers of
the divine nature." Ah, yes, knowledge
of God and the application of that
knowledge by the power of the Spirit is
the means whereby we connect to the
divine power of God. So, when the person
says, "How can I grow?" requirement one,
the knowledge of God's word, not simply
studied but obeyed. When the Bible talks
about knowledge, it implies obedience to
that knowledge. In Christ's Object
Lessons, page 100, paragraph one, L
White writes, "If studied and obeyed,
the word of God works in the heart,
subduing every unholy
attribute." In Ministry of Healing, page
358, paragraph two, "The reason why the
youth and even those of mature years are
so easily led into sin and temptation or
temptation and sin is because they do
not study the word of God and meditate
upon it as they should." So, the answer
I have to that person is number one,
study the word of God and obey it.
Number two,
pray.
Talk to God. Talk to God. Talk to God.
Number three, of course, introduce
someone else to your savior. So, we have
prayer, we have study, we have personal
outreach to talk about the God who is
working in your life. But if I had to
take one, it would be study the word of
God. You see, in the new world, when sin
is abolished, all is perfect. There's no
need to pray, but we will study and
study and study. Before there was sin,
there was no need to pray, but they
would study the marvels of the wonders
of nature. Study, knowledge, study. When
you're serving a God who's infinite,
you're constantly growing and growing
and growing. It requires knowledge. And
so, growth in grace in Christ, to grow
in grace,
is to study God's word, obey God's word,
and stay in contact with God through
prayer, but Bible study is also contact
with God.
Because you're studying the word of God
in the name of Jesus, through the
enlightenment of the Holy Spirit. And
when Daniel could not understand a
prophecy in Daniel 8, verse 16, the
angel said, "Gabriel, make this man to
understand the vision." And so, we have
angelic assistance that work with us to
understand God's word. So, when you
study, when you gain that knowledge, you
are working with Father, Son, Holy
Ghost, and angels.
Okay.
Now, um there is another question in the
chat. We're going to This is coming from
the online uh audience as well. One
pastor in Florida
said the Sabbath was changed to Sunday
after Jesus' resurrection.
Can you please, I guess, answer that
question?
You know, people can say whatever they
like. I don't know if that's I hope that
pastor is not an Adventist. One pastor
said the Sabbath was changed and tell me
the verses the pastor gave. None.
Because he has none. The fact that
people worship on the first day as is
found several times in in in in
well, not several times, but
Acts chapter 20, I think it's verse 7.
People take that to mean the Sabbath was
changed, but they have no Bible verse.
But if you say the Sabbath was changed
because they met on the first day
in Acts chapter 20 verse 7, then what do
you do with Acts chapter Let's go to
Acts chapter 2.
Let's read verse 46.
Of Acts chapter 2.
And they continuing daily with one
accord in the
>> Wait a minute. They continuing daily.
Uh-huh, go on.
With one accord temple.
>> With one accord, mhm. And breaking bread
from house to house. They were
fellowshipping every day they met to
fellowship because the church was new.
It's the fact that they were being
persecuted drove them together to
support one another. Every day they met
in different houses to worship, pray,
and encourage one another. Am I to
assume all 7 days are the Sabbath
because they met every day? We must
reason when studying God's word. The
word of God cannot change. Go to Psalm
100 and I think it's 11. Let's read 6
and 7.
Psalm 111 6 and 7.
Psalm 111 verses 6 and 7.
6 and 7. All right, I'll take that one.
He hath showed his people the power of
his works. That
>> Psalm 111.
Yep.
Verses
>> 6 and 7. Yep.
Mhm.
Look at Look at Psalm 110 6 and 7. 110,
okay. 6 and see if that's the one.
Okay, he shall judge among the heathen.
No, no, no, no. Psalm
111.
All right, but it may come to me later.
Okay.
>> Where it says God's commandments stand
forever and ever. They done it in
righteousness and truth and they stand
Yes, yeah.
Yeah. Forever and ever. Mhm, mhm. You
cannot change God's God himself cannot
change his law because the law is a
reflection of his character. We must
never forget the connection between God
and his law. The law is an expression of
the very character of God. That is why
it is called the testimony. The law does
not testify of human goodness because
humanity has none. The law condemns
humanity. So, how is it a testimony? In
other words, how is it a witness? It is
a witness of the righteousness of God.
To change the law is to change God,
which is impossible. Now, continuing our
reasoning, we go to Psalm 19 verse 7,
"The law of the Lord is perfect
converting the soul." Something perfect
cannot be changed.
And so, whoever that pastor is, may God
speak to him and bless him eventually
and save him. The law of God has never
been changed. The voice that said,
"Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy" on Sinai in Exodus 20 is the same
God the same voice that I'm on the
sermon on the mount. He said, "Think not
I'm come to change the law of prophets.
I've not come to destroy, but to
fulfill."
The same person, Jesus Christ. Christ
has never changed the law
because the law is an expression of his
very character and his very
righteousness. You do not change
holiness and the law is holy. You do not
change justice. The law is just. You do
not change righteousness. The law is
righteousness. Amen.
All right, we have a We have a question
in the chat. I have to take that one
because
I'm from a new convert. As a new convert
hoping to get baptized soon, I am still
unsure as as a caregiver I should refuse
to work on Saturday and exchange shifts
with my colleagues. What would you share
with that individual?
>> All right, let's pray again. Father in
heaven, as we continue, give us fresh
outpouring of divine wisdom, I pray in
Jesus' name. Amen. Amen. Amen. I'm glad
for that question. May the Lord bless
that person with the desire to observe
God's 7th day Sabbath.
We must do when I say we, those of us in
the medical field. And so many in the
medical field think it's okay to go work
on Sabbath.
We must do everything we can to avoid
working on God's holy day.
In the medical field, you're a doctor or
nurse,
if you're required to go in,
you do only what's necessary to relieve
human suffering. And whatever is paid to
you for that is to be given to the
church. Medical Ministry page 216
paragraph 2. Whatever you're paid must
be given to the church. Why? Because
there's to be no work on Sabbath.
There's to be no activity that generates
income because no manna fell on Sabbath.
Manna may be seen as a living. Then they
they it kept them alive. It fell 6 days,
not 7. And the Bible teaches that the
7th day is not the day to make a living.
I hate to sound so forceful, but I don't
want anyone listening to me confused.
The 7th day Sabbath is not a day to make
a living. That is reserved for Sunday to
Friday. So, if you go in on a Saturday,
you're going simply to do good to
relieve suffering of those for whom
Jesus shed his blood. And any
compensation given you must be
surrendered to the church if you are a
practicing faithful 7th day Adventist.
And so, to my dear friend, do everything
in your power not to go. But if you have
to go, do only the minimum required to
ease suffering because it is within the
standards of the Sabbath to ease
suffering on the holy day. Jesus told
his listeners in Luke chapter 14, "Which
of you shall have an ass or ox fallen
into a pit and will not straightway pull
it out on the Sabbath day?" Even
relieving the suffering of animals is
appropriate on the Sabbath day. The
Sabbath is not a day of suffering. It's
a day of joy. And so, yes, we may ease
suffering, but we're not to work for a
living on the 7th day Sabbath. And there
are no exceptions. So, don't tell me
you're a policeman, you're a fireman, or
an electrician. We are not to make a
living on the Sabbath. And if you make a
living on the Sabbath, it did not come
from God.
Mhm.
So, my next question for you is I find
that many believers struggle with the
assurance of salvation due to the guilt
or shame. What biblical perspective can
help restore peace and confidence in
Christ? Yes, that's a very, very good
question.
As long as there's something called
Calvary
Amen. and the empty tomb, Yeah. there is
no need to question your salvation.
Because everything necessary for your
salvation, for your justification, for
your being made right with God was
accomplished by Jesus Christ. Now, when
you accept that with all your heart and
soul and mind and strength,
according to the scriptures, that's when
you're justified. Now, the question
becomes, how does a justified person
live? This is where sanctification
begins, growing in grace, studying the
word, being exposed to your weaknesses,
confessing them, moving on, having
another weakness revealed to you,
confessing it, moving on. You're
growing, growing, growing. This is the
life of a justified person, the path of
sanctification.
Your eye must always be on Jesus Christ,
his atoning sacrifice, which included
his very difficult life, his battle of
the devil, his voluntary death, his
powerful resurrection, his ongoing
intercessory work. All of that refers to
the atoning sacrifice of Jesus Christ,
which fully satisfied a holy God whose
law was violated. As long as there is
something called Calvary, as long as
there's something called the empty tomb
suggesting Jesus rose and is on the
right hand of God interceding for you,
you need not doubt your salvation. All
you need to make sure is that you're
always surrendering to Jesus Christ. It
must be a daily thing. Lord, I give my
life to you. Every day, first thing in
the morning, last thing at night. Don't
wait to feel saved.
Feeling has nothing to do with
salvation. We live in a world that was
created by "And God said." We live in a
world sustained by that same word. We
must ask ourselves, what does the word
say? Not, how do I feel? You feel one
way on Monday, another on Tuesday. You
feel one way when you pass the exam,
another way when you flunk the exam. But
the word of God abideth forever. It does
not change. And so, to the person asking
the question, the assurance of your
salvation lies in the fact that Jesus
Christ paid the total price for your
salvation from mine. And when your faith
lies in that, even if you're discouraged
for one reason or another, it does not
affect the fact that you are saved and a
child of God in the hand of God. "Those
whom God has given me," Jesus says, "I
will in no wise cast out." God doesn't
cast us out. We remove ourselves from
God's hands. He does not cast us out.
And so, my listening friend, recommit
your life to God and trust in what he
can do for you. He can save you. He can
deliver you from the grasp of the enemy.
He can remove your enemies from your
your life, your earthly enemy. He can do
everything for you. All he asks you to
do is trust him and express that trust
through obedience.
Amen. Amen. Powerful. So, what would you
say to some of those retired or elderly
or people who are sickly and it's not
something that they can change related
to their diet and health. It's just a
stage of life, a season of life they're
in, who are feeling like they are not
able to
they don't have usefulness in their
current position. How would you speak to
them and what counsels would you give
them to continue to spread the gospel?
Mhm. Even if that person can serve the
gospel. Now, that may sound silly.
But the Bible says, "By faith Abel
offered unto God a more excellent
sacrifice than Cain, by which he
obtained witness he was righteous, God
testified by his gifts, and by it he
being dead yet speaketh."
You can serve God at any age and stage
in your life as long as you have a
conscious mind.
And so, if you're old and feeble, unable
to walk, you're bedridden, you're in a
wheelchair, whatever the case may be, if
you are conscious and alive and your
mind functions, you can speak to someone
about God, you can contribute
financially to the cause of the gospel.
There are many ways you can assist. Now,
you may not be like an evangelist who
goes around the world or the bachelor on
television or Mark Finley or whoever
else, but there's always something you
can do. It may be a little thing in your
little corner. When I was a little boy,
we had a song called "Brighten the
Corner Where You Are." I don't hear it
now anymore.
You can brighten your little corner, my
dear friend. You read the gospel, Jesus
was evangelistically successful maybe
with individuals, not with the crowd.
And so, the woman at the well, Zacchaeus
at night, not Zacchaeus and Nicodemus at
night, Zacchaeus in his house, where
Christ had one-to-one encounters, he was
almost always successful, not so with
the large crowd. Wherever you are, you
come into contact with people.
Do they know Jesus Christ? Have they
heard of his love?
Do they know that he's willing to
sustain them, bless them, and save them?
Can you tell them that? Can you keep
some little tracts with you where you
are and just hand them out? Don't try to
do what the Apostle Paul did. Do what
you can do where you are, understanding
that the Lord can use you. That's why he
has kept your life this long.
If he found you useless, he might have
put you to sleep.
Amen. Amen. So, that leads me into my
next question.
In these end times, there's so many
people who are struggling with their
faith, struggling with the idea of
moving into a Sunday law.
Um
what
end times So, when apostasy, spiritual
decline, appears within the church, how
can people remain faithful or just the
fear of what's coming?
How can people remain faithful and their
faith is being shaken? Go to the book of
Acts chapter 20, we read from verse 28.
The book of Acts chapter 20, we read
from verse 28.
Very good question.
Simple answer.
Acts chapter 20. Yes, let's read from
verse 28. Verse 28.
This is Paul addressing the Ephesian
elders. These are his final words to
them, they'll never see him again.
Here's what he tells them.
Take heed therefore unto yourselves and
to all the flock,
>> Mhm. with the which the Holy Ghost hath
made you overseers to feed the church of
God, which he
>> Wait a minute now. Paul tells them,
"Feed the church of God." Why? Keep
reading. which he hath purchased with
his own blood. Mhm. For I know this,
that after my departing shall grievous
wolves enter in among you, not sparing
the flock. Pause. What does that mean?
Grievous wolves to bring spiritual
damage and destruction by error, and
that becomes clear in the next verse.
Also, of your own selves shall men
arise, speaking perverse things to draw
away disciples after them. You know,
Paul realizes when he's gone, the false
teachers, the Jews who require the
keeping all the Mosaic law, will come in
and cause chaos in the church and may
drive out the weak. And Paul is telling
them, "Here is how you can defend the
church. Here is how the church can be
strong." Keep reading verse 31.
Therefore, watch and remember that by
the space of 3 years I ceased
to warn every one night and day
with tears. warn every one night and day
with tears. Mhm. And now,
And now, brethren, I commend you to God
and to the word of his grace,
>> Ah, I commend you to God and to the word
of his grace. What is that word of grace
able to do? Keep reading. which is able
to build you up
>> Yes. and inheritance among all them
which are sanctified. Paul tells the
elders, "Here's my recommendation, teach
the word to the people." Now, go to 1
Peter chapter 5, let's read from verse
1.
1 Peter 5, reading from verse 1. The
elders which are among you I exhort,
Mhm. who am also an elder, Mhm. a
witness of the sufferings of Christ and
also a partaker of the glory that shall
be revealed.
Feed the flock of God which is
>> Read it again now. Peter tells those, I
think in Ephesus
or wherever he was, the church in Rome,
possibly.
The same thing Paul tells the Ephesian
elders, "Feed the church of God." Keep
reading.
Taking the oversight thereof,
not constrained, but willingly, not for
filthy lucre, but of a ready mind.
>> Mhm.
Neither as being lords over God's
heritage, but being ensamples to the
flock. And so, Peter and Paul both tell
the elders, "Teach the word to the
church." When Christ was tempted,
temptation one, Matthew 4 verse verse 4,
he said, "But he answered and said, 'It
is written, Man shall not live by bread
alone, but by every word.'" In these
trying times, what can we do? Hold on to
the word of God. But you can only hold
on to a word you studied and understood.
You cannot hold on to a word you do not
know. And so, our security in these last
days or in any age of the world's
history is to stand on God's word, which
is absolutely reliable and does not
move. Our security is to walk in the
word of God, stand on the word of God,
live by the word of God. This is how
Jesus Christ lived a successful life.
Amen. Thank you. Thank you. Listen. And
by the way, preparation for the time to
come,
you cannot face the time that's coming
if you're not faithful in little things
now. Thank you.
Luke 16:10, "He that is faithful in that
which is least is faithful also in
much." We do not understand God judges
us based on the little things we do. So,
he watches how you function as perhaps a
greeter
before you become head elder. He watches
you as a greeter. And by the way you
conduct yourself, he realizes you're not
fit at any time to be an elder. Are you
faithful in little things now? If you're
not, there is no way you will stand when
the full brunt of the time of trouble
hits.
I have a powerful question that just
came up in the chat. Where should one
start memorizing the Bible? Where?
Any book that you like, that's your
favorite book.
Any book that's your favorite book, but
my recommendation is the Gospel of John.
Now, I will allow the Gospel of John to
explain why I choose the Gospel of John.
Go to John chapter 20, let's read 30 and
of John 20. Here's why I always
recommend the Gospel of John.
John 20:30 and 31.
Okay.
And many other signs truly did Jesus in
the presence of his disciples,
which are not written in this book.
>> Okay, we pause. Now, John says, "Jesus
did many other signs." The word signs
means miracles or wonders. John saw
them, he did them in the presence of the
disciples, they are not written in
John's Gospel. That's what John said.
He's a witness, the other disciples were
witnesses, Jesus did many, many
marvelous works not recorded in John's
Gospel. All right. Keep reading.
And these things, I'm sorry, and these
are written that you might believe that
Jesus is the Christ, Wait a minute now.
John says, "Those I've included in my
Gospel.
Since I saw him do many things." Now,
the Gospel of John only records seven
miracles Christ performed.
After his resurrection, he miraculously
helped the disciples catch some fish.
But essentially, he had seven miracles
before he died. That's all. I think
John's Gospel has the fewest miracles.
Now, John said, "Of all that Jesus did
and I saw him, the other disciples saw
him, so they can check me,
I have chosen these. And the reason why
I've chosen these, here's the reason."
Mhm. 31?
That you might believe that Jesus
>> Yes. is the Christ,
>> Mhm. the son of God,
>> Yes. and that believing you might have
life
>> life through his name. That is the
reason why John's Gospel was written,
that those who studied and read it will
be led into eternal life if they study,
of course, honestly and accept what they
learn. Of course, the whole Bible is
designed to do that, but John is very
specific. I selected events in the life
of Jesus Christ. I, the disciple closest
to Christ, I, the one of whom Ellen
White wrote, "I most perfectly reflected
the character of Christ." I chose these
events in the life of Christ
deliberately, that if anyone studies
this book and obeys, that person will
receive eternal life. And so, I always
recommend the Gospel of John. But again,
if your favorite book is 2 Chronicles,
then start memorizing in 2 Chronicles.
Whatever floats your boat, as they say.
You cannot go wrong. Whether you choose
Genesis or Revelation, start where you
like and be disciplined, be consistent,
be determined, and always seek divine
power to help you. Amen. Amen. Praise
God.
Let me also say this.
If you read the sermons in the gospel in
the book of Acts, there are many sermons
in that book.
The apostles did not have Bibles. There
were no Bibles in those days. When
Christ came to the synagogue in Luke
chapter 4, a roll a scroll was given to
him. He did not bring a Bible. People
did not have Bibles. There were no
Bibles. There were scrolls. Mhm.
Clearly, those disciples studied the
word and have the word in their heads.
So, when you study the sermon in Acts
chapter 2 on the the day of Pentecost,
one third of that sermon is based on Old
Testament quotations. They all came from
Peter's head. When Christ was tempted,
he quoted scripture from his head. And
so, it is essential for spiritual growth
Mhm. to hide God's word in your heart.
Psalm 119, uh verse 11, "Thy word have I
hid in my heart that I might not sin
against thee." Amen. And so, I urge
whoever sent the question, start
anywhere you like, but start and stay
with the the task. You'll be
immeasurably blessed. Your life will
change.
So, with that one thing that we've come
across, we've experienced, we have
numerous people who have challenged us.
I think the one of the questions that
just popped up, we'll touch on this
question that I'm about to ask you. Mhm.
You know that the enemy is attacking
families. He's attacking marriages. He's
attacking our children. He's attacking
homes because if he can take that home
foundation he can cause so much disarray
and so much
and
and God's work. How should a believer
respond when their spouse or children
are not Christians or are struggling
Christians and they carry a deep burden
for their salvation? And how
do they connect them to Christ through
their living even though they're
rejecting?
Now, when you say a believer has members
of the family who are not believers,
were they believers and walked away or
were they never believers? Um regardless
of the case
let's go to 1 Peter chapter 3. See what
Peter tells believing wives about how to
handle their unbelieving husbands. 1
Peter chapter 3, let's read from verse
1.
Likewise, you wives be in subjection to
your own husbands that if any obey not
the word, they are Now, Peter is saying,
"Even though your husband does not
follow the word of God
he's still your husband."
Keep reading. So, that if any obey not
the word, they also may without the word
be won by the conversation of the wife.
Now, without the word doesn't mean
without word of God. It means without a
word from the wife. Without any nagging,
without any constant prodding. Without
that, while they behold your chaste
conversation coupled with fear. In other
words, let your husband see your upright
life. Let him see your respect him as
your husband.
Let him see that. Your chaste
conversation coupled with fear, you
respect him as your husband even though
he's not a believer. Peter says, "Do
that." He's telling the wife. He may be
won by the combination of those two
things.
Now
whether it's your husband or your
children or your relatives
the number one thing they need to see is
that you do have a vital relationship
with Jesus Christ. You're not just
talking from the sides of your mouth,
but they see what Christ is doing in
your life. How many times have we said,
"I prefer a sermon. Show me a sermon
than preach a sermon to me." A sermon in
shoes has more power than a sermon
spoken. And so, Peter tells women who
have unbelieving husbands, "Live an
upright life. Let your husband see that.
Respect him and that will win him to the
cause of God." Of course
the age of your children. Let's say your
children don't believe, but how old are
they?
If you've got a 6-year-old boy, a
10-year-old boy, a 14-year-old boy, he
doesn't believe. He may not believe, but
he has to abide by the rules of your
house. When you go to church, he goes.
When you go wherever, he goes. When
there's worship, he's present or he can
find somewhere else to live and I'm not
joking. And so, it depends on the age of
those in your family. Now, if they're 20
and 24, 25, or 26, they're grown adults.
They do not believe and their behavior
is spiritually harmful in the house,
they have to go.
If I knew 10 different languages, I'd
tell you in 10 different languages. If
their behavior is harmful in the home,
they have to go.
Because nothing must interfere with the
work of God with the
the development of God's character,
sorry, my camera here in the lives of
God's people. And so, the number one
thing for someone with relatives who are
not faithful to God is one, a faithful
life and two, the use of God's word. It
is the word that changes people. It
really is. Let the person see Christ in
you.
And that will have an effect on that
person's life. Do not be discouraged and
pray for them. Remember, when you pray
for others, you're praying to God of
whom it is said he is not willing that
any should perish. 2 Peter 3 verse 8. He
will have all to come to the knowledge
of the truth. 1 Timothy chapter 2 verse
4.
This one. Amen.
>> Thank you so much. Amen. Question. Um I
I just want to say that it's such a
challenge because when we're dealing
with our our teens and our children Yes.
we have to know that making a decision
to remove anything that would hinder the
spiritual life of the home
will do more to glorify God than to keep
to keep that person in the home. And And
it is a challenge as a mother. Mhm. We
experience these things and my thought
has always been I wouldn't want to put
my child
in the street that is going to then keep
them captivated Mhm.
What would you say to those mothers or
those people who would struggle to
remove that 20, 21, 22, 25-year-old
because
you're for me, what I've always thought
is you're essentially pushing them into
the world that you're trying to save
them from.
No, no. Well, that's very kind of you,
but uh
the Bible
the
The Bible tells us from such withdraw
thyself. You know, there's a text that
says, "From such withdraw thyself. Have
no fellowship with the fruitful work of
darkness." You see, if a person's
presence is harmful to the cause of God,
that person has to go. Now, if you're
talking about teenagers and children,
the question arises, how did the child
get to that point?
You see, how did the child get to that
point? Where did the parenting fail? But
if it did fail, then we can't go back
and change the past, then something has
to be done. So, if you're talking about
teenagers who are still under the
authority, they have to follow your laws
and rules and regulations in the house.
You're dealing with adults, they can
find somewhere else to go. Yes, the Lord
is more willing to save them than you
are.
Always remember that. God is more
willing to save them than you are.
Amen. Thank you. Mhm. All right. Um I
know I'm looking at the time here. I
want to respect it. Two more questions.
What is commonly referred to as a 2520
prophecy? Does it have any solid
biblical foundation from your
perspective? Trying to
fix my uh Your camera. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's
sliding here. Okay. All right. There you
go. I'll pray one more time. Father, as
we come to the conclusion, continue to
speak through all of us, I pray in
Jesus' name. Amen. This 2520 thing has
bedeviled the church for decades.
When the In 1843, there was a a chart
that the pioneers used, the Millerites.
And that chart had, of course, 1260,
1290. It had a 23 It had a
2300 days and it had 2520. All those
numbers on there.
Ellen White recommended the chart as
very helpful.
And because of that, people think she
was recommending every microscopic
detail on the chart, which is not the
case. She also recommended Daniel
Revelation by Uriah Smith even though it
had some historical inaccuracies, but
overall, it was a great blessing to the
church.
William Miller will be in the kingdom.
Ellen White saw him.
God raised him up, but he made errors.
Martin Luther was raised up by God to
really put the reformation to give feet
to the reformation, but he had no
interest in book of James. He did not
think the book of James should be in the
Bible. He called it a book of straw. And
towards the end of his life, he was very
anti-Semitic. And I think he also
practiced persecution on some people.
Yet, he was raised by God. So, the fact
that God raised up Miller does not mean
everything Miller said was right. Now,
with regard to that chart when the
church was organized in 1863, May 21, I
believe it is, when the general
conference was organized, the day
before, the 20 delegates met. There were
10 from Michigan, about four from New
York, and two from Ohio, two from Iowa,
one from Minnesota, one from Wisconsin,
and some lists have one from Indiana. It
varies between 20 and 21.
They met and made some resolutions. One
of the resolutions was to come up with a
brand new chart. So, these 20 or 21 men,
by the way, there were no women, but
that's those that's that's a bygone era.
They came up with a resolution to come
up with a new chart with a chart for the
10 Commandments and also for the
prophecies.
When that new chart was produced several
months later, the 2520 was gone.
In January of 1864, James White wrote an
article in the Advent Review and Sabbath
Herald, which his wife surely read. And
he said, "We do not see." When he said
"we", he clearly is referring to himself
and the other 19 uh delegates, "We do
not see where 2520 is a prophetic
number. It is not a prophecy. It does
not belong in our teaching, and it was
condemned and discarded." It is
important to know some basics. The book
of Leviticus is not a prophetic book
by any stretch of the most scholarly
imagination. The book of Leviticus is
not a prophetic book. Also, Ellen White
has stated the longest prophecy in the
Bible is 2300 days, not 2520, a number
she has never mentioned in her writing.
And so, the church has condemned that
teaching
for decades, but it is still popular. It
has taken many people out of the church
because they're saying we ought to get
back to 2520 or whatever else that
teaching is supposed to bring to our
attention by those who promote it.
2520 is not a prophecy.
It's found in Leviticus 26 where God
said, "I'll punish you seven times
more." I think verse 18, 21, 24, 28. "If
you don't behave, I'll punish you more."
God is simply saying, "If you do not
behave this way, after a while I'll
punish you again. You still don't
behave, I'll punish you again. I'll
simply increase my punishment if you
persist in your stubborn behavior toward
me." 2520
is not a prophecy. The church has
condemned it. It is not a part of the
church's doctrinal system. Mhm.
Thank you. Thank you for that, uh Pastor
Ski. So,
I have the final question. There are
slews and people know about apologetics.
They want to know about marriage. They
have questions. So, after I ask this
final question and you answer it, we
would appreciate if you can direct us
and those others who may have more
questions in the future. So, my final
question for you
>> Mhm. is Or we can have a part two in the
future. Oh, praise the Lord. I love the
sound of a part two.
We have I have to go back and listen to
this just to take it in and let it
absorb and think in. I'm sure many of
you will as well.
Um but there's many people who have
ministries that have been laid on their
hearts.
>> Mhm. And they are struggling with time
and resources, and we know faith,
prayer. But what counsel and
encouragement would you give to those
people who the Lord has placed a
ministry on their heart? They can see
the vision, but life just seems to
constantly keep getting in the way.
Bills, children, marriage, finances, all
the different things. What counsel would
you give them
in that position?
>> If the Lord has laid a burden on your
heart,
he must make a way for the fulfillment
of that burden into a real ministry.
The Lord cannot place a burden upon you,
require you to carry it, and then put
you on a path with blocks and
impediments and hindrances.
The person must first ask, "Is this
really There are some things we like to
do very, very much. That's our desire.
We can translate that into
a burden from God and call it that when
it is not. So, we have to be sure, "Is
this really a burden or calling from
God, or is this simply something I want
to do?"
If it is a burden and a calling from
God,
then we have to make sure then we trust
God to make the way clear as long as
we're putting his glory, his mission
first.
Can I interject and Before Before Before
Okay, before you do,
the person must also ask God to confirm.
God is a God who confirms. He gave two
visions to Pharaoh in Genesis 41, and
Joseph explained to Pharaoh the reason
why was to make it clear that the the
vision was confirmed. It was from God.
And so, we must ask God, "If this is
from you, confirm it to me." Yes, go on,
sister.
Well, that was exactly is exactly my
question. Okay. What are practical ways
to know that it is a calling and not
just a sensation or feeling that you
have? You ask God to confirm it. Two,
the There must be early evidences that
yes, this is God's work by providing by
sending people your way who can support
you in this mission. These things must
happen to let you know that God is
involved. God cannot call you in
complete darkness, and you have no
evidence that he is leading.
He will send small evidences that he is
pleased and this is his work. If that
does not exist, then you've got to ask
yourself, "Is this really from God?"
Somewhere I read, I'll have to find a
statement Ellen White said, "If you find
your way very, very difficult, you may
be sure you're in the wrong way."
And so, if you think you have a ministry
from God, there must be early
indications that this is from God, and
that can come from support from others,
whether material or by personal
involvement. God must give you small
indications. When God called Moses to go
to Pharaoh, he gave him indications.
Here's a rod. Do this with the rod. He
did not give him everything, but he gave
him indications. He did not know he
would face the Red Sea. He did not know
the plagues would come. He did not know
there would be
hungry people in the wilderness. He did
not know they'd be thirsty. God gave him
small indications with this rod. God
must give you small indications that
this is his choice for you. Ask him to
give them to you. If none of these
things come into your way, then you need
to ask yourself, "Is this really God's
idea for me, or is this my idea?"
Because there's always a way that
seemeth right unto man. David's idea was
to build a temple. God said, "No."
What a lovely idea to build a temple for
God. God said, "No.
Let Solomon do it." And so, your idea to
do this or that and go preach in North
Korea, that may be your idea. It may not
be God's. So, be sure that it is really
a calling from God. Ask God to confirm
it somehow. If it is his calling, he
must confirm it. He does not like his
people functioning in darkness and
doubt. Amen. Amen.
>> Thank you. This has been
such a high and holy moment.
>> a great day, and somebody's asking
Pastor Randy Ski, can we have a part
two? I I I don't know. I'm going
>> Well, not anytime soon.
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
chase after I'm going to chase after him
in the WhatsApp app, and then I'll let
you guys know.
It took It took a year to get him here
today.
I've been chasing after Pastor Randy Ski
for a while.
Do you have a schedule? Someone is
asking is
>> Yes. I don't post it. I don't post it.
You don't post it. That's for
celebrities, you see. That's for
celebrities. I People ask me all the
time, but then I don't post it. You You
an SDA celebrity all the way.
>> I'm not that. I'm not that at all. What
it is is that they want to be able to
watch your sermons. Yeah.
>> Oh, well,
this coming weekend I'll be in Doug
Batchelor's church.
Oh, okay. Uh prayer summit. Myself and
other speakers, I think John Lomacang,
um Doug Batchelor himself. I don't
remember who else will be there.
That's where I'll be. Granite Is it
Granite Hills or Granite Bay SDA church?
Granite Bay.
That's where I'll be this coming week
Not this weekend, next weekend, 16th
through 18th. Amen. And do you have a
YouTube channel called Randy Ski? Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Your family
You just type in Randy Ski on YouTube,
and all the stuff comes up. Up to see
cuz someone's asking is this the real
one? Mhm. It is uh No, that's a good
question. It has some fake It seems like
there's so many channels on There's so
many There's a Facebook channel that I
never opened a Facebook page. Someone
opened it for me uh 10 years ago. I
don't go there.
And then someone People open these
things because they think this message
needs to be heard.
And so, I don't do anything. I just say,
"Fine. If someone is saved, then that's
fine." But yes, there is a YouTube
channel. I can send information to your
good husband after we're finished. Okay.
Wonderful. All right.
>> By the way, pronounce your last name for
me, please. Devallon.
Devallon? Yeah. Okay, Devallon. Thank
you. It's a French French Creole, so
>> That was my guess. Yes. Devallon. Dev-
It's really Devallon in French, but
Devallon. Yeah.
>> Why don't you have people call you
Devallon?
Exactly. He keeps
saying very American. You know, too many
names have been Anglicized, particularly
those of us of color. You know what
happened in Ellis Island. All names were
So, it's Devallon, very lovely sounding
name. Mhm.
Yes. So, the the the the the channel
with your picture is like a family
picture. That's That's yours right
there.
>> Can pull it up.
It is.
Where? This is the one.
>> Uh no, that's not my channel.
And they certainly got your stuff there.
Okay. Well, if someone is blessed,
that's fine. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
not my channel. If I find it If Yeah,
when you send it to me on WhatsApp, I'll
make it public then. I'll let you
>> Okay. All right. Okay. Pastor Randy Ski,
I want to say thank you so much, and
>> You happy Sabbath.
That's been amazing. We never asked
where could people who are have these
questions still burning that they'd like
to get answers from you. Where can they
go? How can they contact That's That's
That's a That's a tricky question, you
see.
All right. Answering questions is
time-consuming.
Mhm.
And when you have a busy schedule,
it's not you don't care, but it's
time-consuming.
Mhm.
Now, I always tell members, "Don't you
have a church pastor?" That's the
function of a church pastor, answer
questions for the members. Mhm. It
really is. It's not just being at every
church board, at every business meeting,
and in everything in the church. The
primary function of a pastor is teach
the word to God's people,
answer the questions, enlighten them.
And so I urge people ask your pastor.
Because this person is a very busy
person.
Once again, uh Pastor Lindesky, thank
you so much. Thank you for your time and
thank you for your counsels and thank
you for the
>> God bless you both very much and doubly
bless your son. Amen. Would you Yes,
thank you so much. We're going to give
you the final word and a closing word of
prayer as well. Would you mind? Mhm. All
right. My final word is simple.
As I said earlier,
Genesis 1:3, and God said, "Let there be
light."
The world was created by the word of
God.
We read in 2 Peter 3:7, "But the heaven
and the earth which are now by that same
word kept in store." The world is
sustained by the word of God.
Matthew 8:16, "And he cast out the
devils with
Satan is conquered by the word of God."
Jesus forgives sins by saying you are
forgiven. My point is everything is done
through the word of God. Consequently,
it makes all the sense in the world to
study the word of God, live by the word
of God.
In so doing, you will develop into the
kind of person fit and suited for a
place in God's coming kingdom. My dear
friend, wherever you are, study God's
word, obey God's word, commit some to
memory,
and one day when Jesus Christ comes, he
will take you home with him and your
family who I hope will follow your
example of studying the word of God. Now
I'll pray. Father in heaven,
thank you very much for this time
with your children. Thank you for the
ministry.
Thank you for those who listen, dear
God. Thank you for those even now making
decisions to change their lifestyle with
the help of your Holy Ghost.
In the name of Jesus Christ, if we said
anything or I said anything that
offended you, forgive me. And I pray
that you'll bless us, bless the
listeners, doubly bless the little
children who may have listened, and
Father, may we always keep our feet in
the path of righteousness. The path of
righteousness is simply the path of
obedience to thus saith the Lord. Make
us a blessing to others, Father. Bless
your commandment keeping people
worldwide, wherever they are. Be
particularly close to those who live
under difficult circumstances. As the
south comes for some of us, depending on
where we are, let us, Father, enter into
that mindset that is fit for the holy
day. Keep us under your care. Let others
come to know Christ because of us and
save us when you come, dear God, without
losing one. I pray from my heart in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. Praise God. Praise God. Well,
someone is looking forward to a sermon
on how to be an apologetic.
Mhm. How to be a what?
An apologetic. And should they be an SDA
apologist?
Well, an apologist, oh, okay. I see.
Yeah. Well, you did some apologetics and
being an apologist. Mhm. All right. All
right. Okay. I I am, too. I think that's
going to be huge in these end times.
Absolutely. Yes. Yes. That's God. The
word of God gets it done if you study.
Mhm. Mhm.